[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 165 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel,
and this week, I
am delighted to be
joined by Brian Dorsey.
Brian, how are you doing?
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
Hello, Mark, and
hello, everyone.
MARK MANDEL: So Brian, I know
this isn't your first time
on the podcast, but it is the
first time you're being host.
Do you want to tell people
a little about yourself?
BRIAN DORSEY: There is nothing
interesting to know, but--
MARK MANDEL: I
disagree, but go ahead.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm also
a DA on Google Cloud.
I love me some Python,
trying to learn some Go, fly
remote control
things, [WHIRRING]
and on the cloud
side, really have
just kind of like
tried to pay attention
to all the different ways we
have to run stuff everywhere,
all the different
compute options we have,
taking in all that stuff.
MARK MANDEL: I think actually
it's entirely your fault that I
got involved with Kubernetes.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, maybe.
MARK MANDEL: I think
it was about a week
into me joining Google Cloud.
You were like, yes, so
I'm teaching a Kubernetes
workshop tomorrow.
Does anyone want to help
be teacher's assistant?
And I was like, sure, I'll
learn Kubernetes overnight.
And so I did.
BRIAN DORSEY: I think
that says something
more about you than me.
MARK MANDEL:
[LAUGHS] Probably so.
So I blame that entirely on you.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'll take it.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So yeah, this week, we have
Dustin Ingram joining us.
He is going to be talking
to us all about Python.
So that's going to be good.
After that, we have a question
of the week, where you're going
to be asking me something fun.
So we are going to talk to
me about manipulating images
with Cloud Functions, which
should be interesting.
But before we do
that, why don't we
get stuck into our cool
things of the week?
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So my first cool
thing of the week
is a blog post on
the Google blog
called Machine Learning can
Boost the Value of Wind Energy.
This is talking about how
Google has been experimenting
with using machine
learning to improve
the prediction of the output
of wind farms essentially.
And unfortunately, wind
doesn't blow at a constant rate
all the time.
So due to its very
variable nature,
being able to predict
what sort of output
you're going to get
from it is usually
very valuable because that's
what you can tell the power
grid, that you're having an
advance and that kind of stuff.
So they've managed to make
significant improvements,
actually, on prediction of
wind power output over 36 hours
ahead of actual generation.
BRIAN DORSEY: Ah, OK.
MARK MANDEL: And has boosted
the value of their wind energy
by roughly 20%.
So we'll put a link to the
article in the show notes
so you can dig into exactly
what it is they've done there.
But yeah, kind of neat
stuff for renewable energy.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Well, there's a lot
of things that would be
more valuable if we knew
about them 36 hours in advance.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
[LAUGHTER] Yes, I can
think of a lot of things.
Yeah, if mistakes that I'm about
to make 36 hours in advance,
I would like to know that.
That would be great.
BRIAN DORSEY: Sign me up.
That's a service I'm
interested in as well.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
BRIAN DORSEY: So my thing
is Compute Engine guest
attributes, which
is kind of specific,
but all of our computer
environments and Compute
Engine, in particular, expose
kind of key value pairs
about the machines via this
thing called the metadata
service.
And you can edit the host
name, and instance ID,
and other kind of stuff.
And so you can build
scripts that kind of monitor
your whole fleet or
tell what's going on,
all that sort of stuff.
And we've just added
in beta the ability
to mix your own data in with
that, which seems pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I got another one here as
well from one of my friends
up in Japan.
One of our sales teams
members, Samir Hammoudi,
who I've worked
with previously he
wrote an article for a
company that he works with
called [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] a Japanese
mobile game company
that's very, very well
known over in Japan.
But they did something really
cool in the open source land.
They actually released a open
source driver for Cloud Spanner
for the Laravel PHP framework.
I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly,
which is a very popular
framework for PHP.
The GitHub repo
is all in English.
You can read that.
The blog post here
is all in English.
If you read Japanese, you
can read more about it
through that.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
But you can have a look
at Samir's summary there.
But yes, if you're using Laravel
and you want to use Spanner,
this is actually a really
nice way of doing it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Nice.
And more information from Japan
about global things, Shunji
Kawabata wrote a
really nice blog post
all about different ways
to run Redis on GCP.
MARK MANDEL: Oh neat.
BRIAN DORSEY: And in case
anybody's not familiar,
Redis is an in-memory key value
store with really rich data
types around the values.
And you see it just
in architectures
for so many large projects.
He's kind of gone through all
the different ways to run them
and pros and cons
about each of them.
It's just really nice to see
it kind of all in one place.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
very, very cool.
I will definitely
check that out.
Awesome.
Well, I think it's
about time that we
go have a chat with
Justin and talk
about all the Python things.
BRIAN DORSEY: And pythons.
Pythons-- rah-- on planes.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Pythons
don't make rah noises,
I'm pretty sure.
BRIAN DORSEY: [LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: This week,
I am delighted to say
we are joined by Dustin Ingram,
developer advocate for Python,
to talk to us all about
all the Python things.
Dustin, how are you doing today?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Hey, Mark.
I'm doing great.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent, excellent.
Thank you so much
for joining us,
and I know Brian's pretty
excited to talk to you, too.
DUSTIN INGRAM: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Before we get sucked into all
the Python things, though,
Justin, do you want to tell
us a little about who you are
and what you do here at Google?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Yeah, so I'm
a developer advocate here
at Google at Google Cloud.
And my focus is on Python,
on the Python community,
all of our Python users,
everything that we
do with Python, basically.
So I've been working with
Python for a really long time.
And I joined Google
about six months ago.
And just really loving working
with Python and the community
and cloud and all the
things that overlap there.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I'm not particularly
familiar with Python.
It's not something I
for whatever reason just
happen to run into.
So for those people who
aren't familiar with Python,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about the language,
and what it's good for, and
all that kind of fun stuff?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Python is
an interpretive language.
So that means that it's not
compiled like C or something
like that.
It's sort of every
time you run Python,
it interprets the language.
Python's also dynamically typed,
so unlike some other languages,
you don't have to
specify the types,
like if this is a string, or if
it's an integer, or whatever.
And then more generally,
Python's just kind of like
a pretty high level language.
It's super readable.
So since the very beginning,
Python's had a really strong
focus on code readability.
So a lot of people
like to say that Python
is like runnable pseudocode.
So it kind of looks
like something
that you would write
that's pseudocode,
and it also kind of
looks just like Python.
So for that reason,
people really like it.
Beginners really like it because
it's easy to pick up and learn.
It looks very readable.
Folks just like
it when they want
to be able to read
their code, I guess.
MARK MANDEL: So OK, great.
So are there any particular
great use cases for Python?
Is there things you would be
like, this is the perfect thing
to use Python for?
DUSTIN INGRAM: I'm
totally biased here
because I like to use
Python for everything.
And one of the really nice
things I think about Python
is that if you really want to,
you can use it for anything.
Something else that people
like to say about Python
is that it's the second best
language for everything.
So basically, if
you want to do it,
you could probably
do it in Python.
It might not be the fastest
or easiest 100% of the time,
but definitely possible to do
pretty much anything you want.
Python is super popular
for web applications.
So a lot of real big name
groups run their large services
on Python, so like Instagram,
for example, it's all Python.
It's all Django.
And other similar kind
of large scale things
like to use Python, and
data science as well.
So a lot of folks do data
science and machine learning
and stuff with Python
mostly because that stuff
is hard enough as it is.
So as long as you
can read your code
and write meaningful
code with Python,
it sort of helps abstract away
some of the more complex parts
of that, I guess.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, I do have to
have a follow up on this one,
though.
You said almost everything.
So what would you not use
Python for, or what would you
maybe not recommend people
use it as a first choice for?
DUSTIN INGRAM: So because
Python's interpreted,
that means we're not compiling
something down to a binary.
And it means that it's a
little bit slower to run.
Just the fact that it's
interpreted makes it slower.
So anything that's like--
would be super performance
heavy, probably not
great to use with
Python, although there's
all sorts of workarounds for
making Python really fast.
And I'm specifically
talking about the Python
interpreters is written in C.
So that's what we call C Python.
And that sort of is a relatively
mediocre or slow interpreter.
It's kind of designed to
work well and not necessarily
for performance optimizations.
There are other Python
interpreters, though.
So there's also PyPy, which
is self-hosted Python,
and it's real fast.
So depending on
what you want to do,
you can kind of make
Python a little bit faster.
But generally, if you're
doing anything that's really
CPU bound or IO bound,
Python's maybe not
going to be the best choice.
You might want to write
a little bit of C,
or a little bit of Rust,
or something like that.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
sitting here trying
to think of terrible ideas.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, we can have
a whole other conversation
about--
MARK MANDEL: That's
a whole episode.
BRIAN DORSEY: Terrible ideas.
OK, so let's say--
which actually is pretty true--
I am a Python person.
And I'm curious, what can I do
in Google Cloud with Python?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Right
out of the bat,
putting your Python application,
your web application
on Google Cloud is like one of
our number one use cases here.
So way back in the day, when App
Engine came out, which I think
was over 10 years ago now--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
DUSTIN INGRAM: It was one
of the very first platform
as a service type
things for Python.
So it was kind of one
of the first places
that you could take a Python
web application and deploy it.
Obviously, it's changed
a lot since then.
That's still something
that a lot of people
come to Google Cloud
to do with Python.
We still have App Engine.
We have Compute Engine as well.
We have App Engine Flux
and Cloud Functions.
And all these sort of play a
little bit different roles,
but in the end, you're
kind of always deploying
a Python application or some--
for functions, it's just a
function to Google cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
How do you go
about like choosing
which platform is a good fit?
Because you just said we've got
like seven different things.
It's fine.
DUSTIN INGRAM: You
gotta roll the dice.
I don't know.
Yeah, so we do.
We have a lot.
They do serve different
use cases, though.
So let's start with the
original App Engine.
The original App Engine made
a lot of choices for you
about what runtime
was available to you,
like system level
libraries, things like that.
And you didn't get to
really change that too much.
We sort of picked
a couple packages,
put them in the runtime for
you, and they were there.
You could bundle some extra
bytes on dependencies.
It was pretty restrictive.
And again, that
was 10 years ago,
so things have
changed a little bit.
The new App Engine, you want
to use that if you kind of want
a consistent base image.
So it's Ubuntu under the hood.
But you want to be able
to install like whatever
dependencies you want, anything
from PyPI or anywhere else.
Yeah, and if you
just want to respond
to web traffic, that's what
App Engine is really good for.
Cloud Functions, also
kind of like that.
You can also sort
of write something
that kind of looks like a web
application in Cloud Functions.
But that would just be
basically a function that
responds to an HTTP request.
So it would be like a single
end point in your application
would be a single function.
But then if you don't
want to do HTTP at all,
Cloud Functions are great for
triggers across all of GCP.
So one really common
example is you
want to do something with a
file after it's been uploaded
to your storage bucket, so Cloud
Functions is perfect for this
because you can sort of
hook into the events that
are happening, see every
time this file is out
of this bucket, do this thing.
And then you just write a
little function in Python.
It gets some information
about the event,
and you can do whatever.
And then beyond that,
the rest of the platform
is starting to just add
additional customized ability.
So like Flex, you can really
customize the runtime.
If you need to do really
specific video encoding stuff--
I know some of our customers
do that-- they use Flex
because they can just really
install exactly the system, all
the libraries, really
fast libraries, whatever
they need to do to do
a really specific task.
It works well for that.
MARK MANDEL: So here's
a fun question for you.
I'm writing Python,
and I've decided
App Engine is the way I
want to go to begin with.
And then I'm running
stuff on App Engine,
and I've realized maybe
I've made the wrong choice.
What does the
developer experience
look like for each
of those tools?
Is it easy enough
for me to shift,
or I suppose it just
depends what I'm building,
or what's your thoughts there?
DUSTIN INGRAM: It
kind of depends
on what you're building.
And so yeah, let's just
talk about the latest--
the new App Engine
runtime is Python 3.7.
We're calling it the idiomatic
App Engine standard runtime.
Moving off of that would be
super easy because there's
nothing really locking you
into that runtime that's really
specific to App Engine, right?
Our getting started example,
for example, a lot of people
are super familiar with Flask.
Flask is a micro framework for
web applications in Python.
And we just tell you
to write a Flask app,
and then you deploy
that to App Engine.
And that Flask app, you
can take that anywhere.
You can take that to Heroku.
You can take that AWS,
anywhere you want.
It's going to work
the exactly same way.
There's not going to be
anything specific about it
for App Engine.
So it's pretty portable.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, I
have a follow up here.
You kind of alluded a couple
times to original App Engine,
or you kind of said things
are different a little now.
So for Python people who've
been around for a while
and what they knew of App Engine
is when it first came out,
or they looked at it
six or eight years ago.
What's changed?
What is new App Engine?
Why should I care?
MARK MANDEL: Are we in, like,
App Engine classic mode?
Is it like our original
recipe or something?
[MUNCHING] Mm!
DUSTIN INGRAM: It's like a
retro App Engine and then
futuristic App Engine.
I shouldn't call it
retro App Engine.
So part of the problem
is they're both
called App Engine standard.
One's at Python 2 runtime,
one's Python 3 runtime.
So the big difference is well,
one's Python 2 and one's Python
3.
That's a huge win for
a lot of our users.
So just having Python 3 runtime
that's immediately available
is really great.
And then, yeah, Python
2 App Engine standard,
we make a lot of
decisions for you.
We provide only a certain
set of system libraries
out of the box.
It's harder and possible
to install other ones.
If you want to install
your dependencies,
like Python dependencies,
you kind of have to--
what's called vendoring
them into your application.
So it's really like copying
the source code, including
at bundling it up
with your application
and deploying the
whole thing at once.
The new App Engine
runtime is great
because you just specify a
file called requirements.txt.
This is a list of packages that
are available on the Python
Package Index.
And then when your App
Engine instance gets created,
we go to PyPI, we
download the packages,
we install them
into the instance.
And then when your application
goes run, then it's there.
So it removes a whole lot
of this developer pain
about rendering things.
And it also makes
it easier for us
to install built distributions
and all that kind of stuff that
comes along with the sort of
idiomatic Python packaging
environment.
MARK MANDEL: Here
at Google Cloud,
we definitely do a
lot of containers,
especially for workloads in
which may not necessarily
fit into that web paradigm.
Are there any best practices
for running containers
with Python or anything
people should be aware of?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Yeah, it's
pretty standard and idiomatic
container stuff.
So if you're
familiar with Docker,
I mean, using Python
with containers
is pretty straightforward.
One thing about Python that
is kind of interesting-- it's
kind of hard to ship
a Python executable.
So something that would
not require an interpreter
or something along with it.
So a lot times, people are
deploying Python in containers.
They're installing
Python, and then they're
writing a Python app.
And those two things
are kind of separated.
There are a lot of kind
of third party approaches
to bundling together the
runtime and your user code
into a single thing.
And then you can go install that
on a computer, user's machine.
But if you're using containers--
Ubuntu ships with Python in it.
So it's already there.
You're just going to make sure
you have the right version
and then go and write your code.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
I'm convinced I want to
try some Python on GCP.
And I'm a Python developer.
Where do I get started?
DUSTIN INGRAM: I really like
this about our documentation
right now.
So this is kind of a secret.
Cloud Functions under the
hood is just a Flask app.
So we talked about Flask before.
That's microservice
web framework.
Under the hood,
that's just Flask.
So for App Engine, when we
show in our documentation stuff
like that, we're just showing
you really simple examples
with Flask.
So if you want to get
started, what I would say
is go to the Flask
documentation,
and take their quick
start, and just try and get
a Flask little web application
running on your machine.
And then see if you can
take that and bring it
to Google Cloud
because it should be
really straightforward, right?
It should just be
you take it, you
add a little bit of
a command line magic
to set up the project
and deploy it,
and then it should just work.
So that's what I'd
recommend because I
think that kind of shows the
nice path of taking an existing
application and bringing
that to Google Cloud.
You don't need to write anything
special just for App Engine
or just for Cloud Functions.
Then the other fun
thing you can do
is you can take your individual
end points of your function
and then try and break that
apart into microservices
and put them on Cloud Functions.
Because then it's just sort
of just the same thing.
MARK MANDEL: And
for someone like me
who has never really
played with Python,
where should I go to
learn about Python itself?
DUSTIN INGRAM:
One thing I really
love about Python, the
community and the documentation
is generally excellent,
very well maintained, just
super easy to follow usually.
I'm definitely
biased because I've
been looking at the same
documentation for a long time.
So I would recommend
docs.python.org
is all of the documentation
about specific Python
standard library and runtimes.
And then a huge part of Python
is the community of libraries
that come along with it.
So when you install Python,
you get the Python interpreter
and your standard library.
And then if you want more, you
can come to the Python package
index and install--
last time I looked,
there was, like,
170,000 different projects.
They all do different things.
So you can go and
install something there.
All those things have their
own documentation generally.
It's pretty good.
So I would start
with core Python.
If you take a Python
course, there's
lots of community supported
Python 101 type things.
BRIAN DORSEY: So as a
longtime Python user,
when you were kind
of exploring GCPs,
was there anything
that surprised or made
you really-- actually
surprised either way,
but kind of especially
like surprise
made you really happy about
how people do things on GCP
or how things worked?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Yeah,
so it's actually
kind of funny because
my background,
I spent a lot of time working
on Python packaging stuff.
So I'm the maintainer of
the Python Package Index.
I work on some of
the packaging tools
for installing packages,
that kind of thing.
And when I got hired to be a
developer advocate for Python,
in the back of my mind--
everyone has this
imposter syndrome thing.
In the back of my mind, I was
like, do I really know that
much about--
I kind of know a lot about
this packaging thing.
I don't really know that much
about maybe Python in general.
And then when I got hired, I
realized most people's problems
are with packaging stuff.
So I was pleasantly
surprised to find that.
But that's not what you want
to hear, is that like, oh,
I was surprised that
our users were having
lots of packaging problems.
So I was software
consultant before.
I had not really
used GCP too much.
Used some of the other services.
I remember when the original App
Engine came out and remembered
it being kind of weird
and all the things
that came along with it.
And I didn't really
actually even know.
I guess, maybe we hadn't
even launched it yet,
so maybe that's
why I didn't know.
But I didn't know
that we were going
to get this cool new Python
3.7 App Engine runtime.
And so when I found
out that we had that
or we were about to launch it,
I was like, this is so cool.
This is exactly
what it should be.
I was really happy to see
that you can just install
dependencies, all that stuff.
And that it solves a lot
of those packaging problems
that I had seen people
having, so I guess
it shouldn't have surprised
me that Google was working
on that before I started.
But yeah, it was a
pleasant surprise for sure.
MARK MANDEL: On that
wavelength, what's
been the most interesting or--
yeah, let's just say
interesting thing
that you've seen somebody do
with Python that's kind of also
caught you by surprise?
DUSTIN INGRAM: I remember we had
a Py Con a couple of years ago.
I don't remember
which one it was.
This was maybe like
five years ago,
so sort of before the time when
we had nice object recognition
machine learning algorithms
that you can just build a model
and plug it into Python.
I don't remember what
his name, but this fellow
had-- basically, he was having
a problem with squirrels eating
the bird seed in his backyard.
So what he had done
with Python, he
had created this image
video recognition
thing that could pick out
a squirrel in an image.
And he had a water
gun on a [INAUDIBLE]
that could aim and squirt
some water at the squirrels.
And I remember seeing
that at the time.
I think it was either like a
talk or maybe a landing talk
at Python.
And I remember
being like, wow, I
didn't know you could do
all that stuff with Python.
Because that's so much.
It's controlling the motors.
It's doing the image
recognition and all that stuff.
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
DUSTIN INGRAM: As far as
technically challenging
or interesting things people
have done with Python,
I mentioned before that there's
alternative interpreters
for Python.
So PyPy is the self-hosted
Python interpreter.
I have dug into the
source code a little bit,
and it's mind boggling.
But basically, it's
Python hosted on Python.
It's Python interpreting
other Python code.
So the point when a
language self-hosts itself
is pretty interesting.
And PyPy is not exactly Python.
But the point at which Python
started self-hosting itself,
I think, was a huge achievement.
Really technically
interesting to see
how you can write Python code
to interpret Python code.
It goes right down the
rabbit hole basically.
But yeah, that's a pretty
interesting project as well.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, you
said something interesting.
Before, you said there's
a C implementation that's
not that fast and a Python
implementation that's
way faster?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Yeah, you might
be surprised to hear that.
So I'm not a Python
core developer,
but I kind of like pay
attention to what's going on.
I think the general feeling
about creating and working
on the Python interpreter
is that they're not really
trying to make it super
performance optimized.
They want it to be
bug free, and they
want to be able to add
new features to it,
have it be readable for
the core and developers.
And so, yeah, it doesn't
receive a whole lot
of optimization, which is fine.
I think that's totally fine.
PyPy is interesting
because-- and this
is starting to get a little bit
outside of what I totally know.
But they do a
whole bunch of just
in time, kind of like it kind
of looks like compiling Python
beforehand, which--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
DUSTIN INGRAM: Speeds it
up quite significantly.
I've seen people say anywhere
from like 5 to 10 times faster
when using PyPy.
But--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
DUSTIN INGRAM: It comes with
a whole bunch of caveats
as well, so beware.
MARK MANDEL: Are there
any particular events
that you would recommend
that people go to, either
to learn about Python or
get involved with the Python
community?
DUSTIN INGRAM: Yeah, absolutely.
So Python is great.
I think Naomi Cedar said
at one point in a talk
that she was giving-- so
she's a Python person.
Python, come for the language,
stay for the community.
So Python has a really
excellent community,
a lot of events that happen.
Really kind of like a
grass roots type of thing,
not a lot of corporate
Python events, I think.
So the big one that I've been
to a lot that I really enjoy
is Py Con.
Py Con takes place once a year.
It usually doubles up, so it
was in Cleveland last year.
It'll be in Cleveland
in May this year.
And it's like, this year
about 3,500 Pythonistas
descend on the tiny
town of Cleveland
at the convention center.
It's just really great.
It's like multiple
days of talks.
There's tutorials.
There's development
sprints afterwards.
And it's just a great event.
It's really community oriented.
There's also like a huge--
so Google will be there.
We'll have a huge
booth, huge expo hall,
and other Python
shops that are hiring
or do interesting
things with Python.
It's a great event.
That said, there
are so many really
super excellent small
community Python events, too.
So I just got back from Py
Caribbean, which kind of sounds
a little bit like a joke.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
DUSTIN INGRAM:
Yeah, it's February.
MARK MANDEL: No, it
sounds fantastic.
That sounds awesome.
DUSTIN INGRAM: Someone
had the brilliant idea
of hosting a Python conference
in the Caribbean in February.
And turns out it's not just an
excuse to go to the Caribbean.
It was a really
amazing conference.
It was in the Dominican
Republic this year.
They just did such a great job.
It's so interesting to see
the community there as well.
And it's just as
strong as anywhere--
and I've traveled all
over and seen all sorts
of Python communities.
And they're just like
great, strong, very
cohesive communities.
A lot of people
working really hard
and trying to mentor each
other, elevate each other.
MARK MANDEL: So Dustin,
before we let you go,
is there anything
we haven't managed
to ask you that you want to make
sure it gets on the podcast?
Are you going anywhere,
doing anything,
releasing any content,
or just something cool
that you want to make
sure gets on here?
DUSTIN INGRAM:
Yeah, so I'm going
to be giving a talk
at Google Cloud Next.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
DUSTIN INGRAM: I'm
going to talking
about porting your code
from Python 2 to Python 3
with kind of like specific
focus on Google Cloud.
So that's something that I
get a lot of questions about.
And should be a good talk,
should be interesting.
And it will be published
online afterwards as well.
Also, will be giving
a talk at Python.
So it's probably my favorite
place to give a talk.
So I'll be there.
I also think I'm going to be
in Cleveland for two weeks,
just floating around all of the
events and talking to people.
So really excited to see Python
users there and talk to them
about Google Cloud.
I like talking about just
Python, too, so that as well.
And mostly just excited
about those events.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Dustin, thank you so
much for coming and hanging out
with us on the podcast and
telling us all about Python.
DUSTIN INGRAM: Thanks, Mark.
Thanks, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
Thank you so much, Dustin,
for coming and teaching us
about Python in general
and Python on GCP.
Check him out.
Follow him on Twitter
and all the things.
And let's move on to the
question of the week, shall we?
Here we go.
My question is, Cloud
Functions seem cool.
We can connect all of the
pieces of the internet together.
I think of it as
kind of like glue
for all of the events
and web requests
that you might make
here and there.
But are they only good
for lightweight stuff,
or can I do things that are a
little more binary oriented,
like images and the like?
MARK MANDEL: It's a good
thing that you asked me
about images actually, Brian.
Thank you so much.
BRIAN DORSEY: Was
that leading enough?
MARK MANDEL: We'll have you
back on the podcast definitely.
[LAUGHS] So this is cool.
I found out about this today.
And I was actually kind
of excited about it.
So Cloud Functions
bundles ImageMagick
in with the runtime,
which is really handy.
BRIAN DORSEY: Right,
that sounds super cool.
What's ImageMagick, though?
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
ImageMagick, yes.
So ImageMagick is
a little binary.
You probably have it
on one of your distros,
if you're on Linux
or you run Mac,
or if you run Windows
subsystem for Linux on Windows.
Basically, it's a
command line utility
for doing just about
anything you could ever
think of ever doing to
images, from resizing,
cropping, blurring,
putting together
GIFs that are animated.
Visually, if you can
pretty much think about it,
you could probably do
it with ImageMagick.
BRIAN DORSEY: That
sounds like a challenge.
MARK MANDEL: Find me
something you can't do.
There we go.
That's the thing.
Anyway, so apparently, it gets
bundled with Cloud Functions.
Just so the binaries
there-- usually,
you can get a nice wrapper
library with your language.
I know JS has one, for example.
Or if you really want
to, just run convert.
That's basically the command
line, and pass it through.
But you can do pretty
much whatever you want.
So we're going to link to
a tutorial that's actually
talking about joining Cloud
Functions with Vision API
and ImageMagick to
blur offensive images.
That will take you
through some of the steps.
BRIAN DORSEY: That
sounds useful.
MARK MANDEL: But yeah,
essentially, ImageMagick
lives in the runtime.
So either you can use a
wrapper or use it directly.
So you can basically
do whatever you want.
So yeah, if you wanted to
build a dynamic image resizing
thing for a container or
bucket and then spit that out
on the other side, you could
do that pretty easily, too.
There's really kind of
no limit in some ways.
BRIAN DORSEY: Wow,
that sounds awesome.
OK, I feel challenged.
I'm going to have to try to hit
that up and see if I can find
something that can't be done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm always more on the
other side, where I'm like,
I wonder what the most
ridiculous thing somebody
has done with ImageMagick.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, OK.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There's gotta be some
really ridiculous things.
BRIAN DORSEY: Tweet at us.
I'm curious.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Excellent.
All right, well, I
hope that answers
the question for you, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: It did.
It's amazingly related
to the question I asked.
MARK MANDEL: That is good.
Awesome.
Where are you going?
What are you doing?
Are you up to
anything interesting
that you want our
listeners to know about?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
I think the next
big thing for me,
I mentioned kind of interested
in all of our compute stuff.
And last couple years,
I've given a talk
about how to decide where to run
your code aimed at developers
who are-- we have
multiple blue hexagons
for writing your
different things,
from Functions, App
Engine, Kubernetes, VMs,
the whole deal, right?
MARK MANDEL: We do.
BRIAN DORSEY: So I'm
going to be doing
an updated and much
better version of that
with some new stuff to
talk about at Next, so.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I will also be at Next
doing the podcast.
We have a little
space on the floor.
Brian may show up if I
can rope him into it.
I just volunteered
him right now.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, OK.
I'm in.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I'll be at the Game
Developers Conference
doing a lot of things.
There will be the Google booth.
They'll be giving
a presentation.
There's lots of presentations
all day Wednesday.
There's all sorts of fun things.
So if you can't find anything
to do with Google Cloud and GDC,
and you're really
stuck, just hit me up.
I'm sure I can direct
you to the right place.
And I will also be presenting
in April at East Coast Game
Conference talking about
open sourcing games
and also talking about Agones
and all the other fun things.
I think that's it.
Awesome.
Well, Brian, thank you
very much for joining me
on the podcast this week.
BRIAN DORSEY: Likewise.
Thank you for having
me here, and thank you
to everyone who
listened all this way.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
see you all next week.
BRIAN DORSEY: See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]